[موسيقى] كانت
هذه المدينة القديمة ذات يوم
مركزًا عالميًا لمملكة
بدأت المملكة الأولى التي توحد
المناطق التي خلقت بورما
[موسيقى]
المنطقة الأثرية للصفقة هي
مدينة قديمة تقع في وسط ميانمار
وهي معروفة بأنها مغطاة
بزخارف لا تصدق  المعابد التي
تبرز من السهول الخضراء الكاسحة
والنباتات المورقة تم بناء هذه المعابد من
قبل الملوك في الفترة ما بين 10:57 و
1287 وكان هناك في الأصل حوالي 10000
ومع ذلك اليوم ما يزيد قليلاً عن 2000 لا يزالون في
حالات مختلفة من الإصلاح وقد فقد الآخرون
بسبب  الغزوات المغولية وفي
الآونة الأخيرة الزلازل ،
تتم صيانة المعابد المتبقية
وتخضع لعمليات ترميم مستمرة
للحفاظ عليها سليمة حتى تستمتع الأجيال القادمة
[الموسيقى]
بك